this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
good evening thanks for joining us
tonight at 11 i'm denise feldas and i'm
brian loftis for the second time now in
two days a suspect is dead in a shooting
involving police metro police have been
on the scene of the latest incident now
for hours all right so metro just gave
us an update madison kimbrough is live
at the scene madison
yes this is being labeled as a domestic
disturbance it happened around 6 30 this
evening now take a look behind me as you
can see it's still a very active scene
here on arville and penwood avenue and
when officers arrived on scene the
situation escalated
fire from the suspect
the officers returned fire
and the suspect fled
after a short foot pursuit
the officers reengaged the suspect and
discharged their weapons again
the suspect fell to the ground and
officers immediately rendered aid
the suspect later died on scene now
during this a woman who is said to be
related to the incident was shot but we
are told her injuries are
non-life-threatening and she was treated
at an area hospital one of the officers
at the scene was also injured but was
treated and has since been released this
marks the seventh officer involved
shooting for metro in 2021 of course we
will keep you updated as we learn more
information when more information
becomes available keep it here on 8 news
now reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now